INTERVIEWER: So
here's your moment
of eerie beauty for today.
The desolate landscape
and moody sky
accentuate the
wreckage of this plane,
and set against this
vista is a couple just
barely holding hands.
An old wreck like this hardly
seems like a romantic spot,
and yet they seem lost
in a tender moment.
So why this place?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The image was taken
by this couple.
HALLDORA: Hi, I'm Halldora.
HOBIE: And I'm Hobie.
We are not only a couple,
but also a photo team.
HALLDORA: This photo was
taken at Solheimasandur
on the south coast of Iceland.
INTERVIEWER: Halldora
and Hobie specialize
in wedding photos set against
the dramatic landscape
of Iceland.
In this case, the couple in
the photo-- Amanda and Rich--
have traveled from Philadelphia
to celebrate their anniversary.
They wanted to
document the trip,
so they reached out to Halldora
and Hobie with a suggestion.
HOBIE: I'd always
wanted to photograph
a couple at the plane.
So we were thrilled when Amanda
and Rich contacted us, and said
they were interested
in shooting there.
INTERVIEWER: The
weather-beaten wreckage
is a US Naval plane that
crash-landed landed on the site
in 1973.
The abandoned fuselage against
the expansive, frozen black
sand beach made for a great
location for the shoot.
And with some encouragement,
Amanda and Rich
climbed on top of the plane.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HOBIE: Once they
were up there, they
were so immersed in
the view that they soon
forgot we were even there.
They were truly
enjoying the moment
with each other, which made
for some spectacular photos.
INTERVIEWER: It's
moments like these
that make Halldora and
Hobie really appreciate
what they do for a living.
HOBIE: Photography was
our common interest
that brough us together.
Everything we do is
related to photography.
We love exploring
new landscapes,
searching for that
next amazing place
to photograph a couple at.
HALLDORA: Photography
pushes us to go further,
to never stop exploring.
INTERVIEWER: And
there's no doubt
that the varied and dramatic
Icelandic scenery gives them
endless opportunities to capture
some really stunning images.
HOBIE: Photographing
couples in love
in a country filled with
sparkling, white glaciers,
black sand beaches, moss
covered lava fields,
vivid northern lights,
and blue hot springs.
There are few
places where you can
find both volcanoes and
glaciers, side by side
in the same country.
Making Iceland commonly referred
to as the Land of Fire and Ice.
There's no better
backdrop for a wedding.
INTERVIEWER: If you
liked this video,
be sure to check out this one
on extreme adventure racing
across Patagonia.
SUBJECT 1: It just takes
my breath away every time
I go there.
SUBJECT 2: And we've
climbed unknown mountains
while racing, we've rafted
on our little Therm-a-Rests
down unknown rivers,
days without sleep.
INTERVIEWER: And don't forget
to click the subscribe button
Thanks for watching.